[Music]
hey there and welcome back to stylecraft
we are focused on movement and direction
and for this third video i want to
show you
how you use movement direction with the
3d camera and this is where things get a
lot more interesting
for me personally i love to use the 3d
camera
and the majority of the motion graphics
that i do because with the 3d camera
there's so much more
possibilities with the movement it's
easier for me to control the 3d camera
and to do moves that are you know in and
out side to side up and down whatever
the moves are i find it much easier to
animate an overall scene or multiple
scenes
with the 3d camera
versus
parenting everything to one single null
and trying to move things around that
way so that's just my own personal
workflow i'm a big believer that 3d
camera can make your life
a lot easier too in motion graphics if
you
can grasp
the power that it has
with movement and direction so
here we are in after effects
and for this first example we're going
to build upon what we've already learned
and i'm going to show you um how to use
uh nulls to make your motion more
interesting so the first thing i'm going
to do is i'm going to add
a 3d camera
it's going to be a onenote camera 35
millimeter doesn't really matter what
click ok
you can see that immediately our image
changed if i undo that
and then redo it
you can see that changes because what i
have here are two layers three layers in
a composition
[Music]
and this is the camera view
and this is the custom side view there's
my camera there's the back layer it's
just masked out this
circular
illustration and then the circular
illustration has a mass added to it and
it's pulled forward in z space by
negative 300 pixels
and the one the back is a thousand
pixels pushed back on z so
just so you understand that these are
two layers in 3d space
with a camera so if i was to move the
camera around with my orbit tool you're
gonna see that
here you can really see the three layers
so undo that undo that
and so we've got our camera move it to
the front and this black layer is just a
solid background layer so i'll lock
these layers
here's my 3d camera and we can add a
null just like we did on the previous
examples
make that null 3d and i can parent my
camera to that null
and by doing this
now i can set a keyframe for the y
rotation for example
go to the end of my timeline here at
three seconds
and let's say i set another keyframe
one rotation so what we're going to do
here is the camera is going to rotate
around
this image right
i've been asked that a lot like well how
do you make the 3d camera rotate around
an object that's just centered in z
space well it's super simple you just
put a null object there and you rotate
around it so
so what i'm going to do here i'm going
to duplicate these two layers
i'm gonna turn the mask off
just to give you a better idea here i'm
going to center the position at zero
because our null is also
at a position of zero in z space so now
if i rotate around you can get a better
idea of what i'm doing here
uh same thing goes for let's say we
wanted to
turn the y rotation off let's say we
wanted to do a
z rotation right
same kind of deal
very easy
so now let's say we want to make the
move a little bit more complicated right
we want the
y rotation
to go one full rotation like we did
previously
and as we're doing that
we also want to say want the camera to
move on the z rotation so we could just
set a keyframe for the z rotation here
and then we have this kind of move
right so just very simple examples of
how we can use nulls with a 3d camera
to make more complicated
moves
in 3d space there's a lot more we could
do with that in fact i have a video up
on youtube
how to make a spiral path with a 3d
camera someone asked me that oh maybe
like a year ago and i made a video about
that so if you want to check out motion
science
on youtube
you'll see a video there about how to
use knowles to make
3d cameras
do more complicated moves so that's the
first example
turn this layer off turn these ones back
on
now i want to show example where we use
a motion path so remember in the
previous lesson we made a spiral here's
that same spiral i'm going to edit
copy
so i'm back in after effects
open up my position
i'm going to go edit
paste
and
there's our spiral now on the camera we
need to back the
z space up here so we'll do that
and what we've got here is a very simple
spiral with a 3d camera so just like
motion pass can be pasted on objects
shape layers text that kind of thing you
can also be pasted on the position layer
of a 3d camera we can also drag the
keyframe out here for roving
keyframes to extend our move if we want
to do that
just like the shape layers
so you get the idea there
and let me delete that and let me reset
this
just like
i showed you with
motion sketching we can do the same
thing here the only thing we need to do
here is we need to add a null object
so we'll add the null object we'll make
it 3d
and we'll back up to zero
and for this example i'm gonna go ahead
and
extend my timeline
go back to motion sketch we're gonna
capture at let's say fifty percent speed
well let's do a two
i'm smoothing and what i'm going to
replicate here is kind of like a
handheld look okay so i'll hit start
capture
that's right
so you saw the so hit start capture you
see an error here cannot motion sketch
3d layers that's okay so we'll click ok
we'll turn off the 3d layer
go back to start capture and i'll show
you why in just a minute so here we go
we're
capturing know i'm doing like a little
handheld look here so the movement is
going to be pretty subtle unless we hit
it like a bump oh we hit a bump there
and we're smoothing back out again
yeah pretty close yep looks nice nice
handheld look
okay
now what we're going to do is we're
going to parent our camera to the null
object
and we are going to
preview this
and here is our very
simple
handheld look okay so if we want to do
the opposite now we want to create like
a really smooth handheld look what i
might try and do is i might capture at
let's say 200 percent
smooth it out to let's say five
start capture
here we go and this is just going to
slow it way down
so now if we preview
so what i would do now is i'd probably
delete a few of these keyframes
maybe drag a few of them out
it's nice because we get a nice like um
imperfect look by doing this
maybe even a few more
let's see what that looks like
yeah now to get rid of that jitter
also easy ease
that looks nice now for the last thing
on here
what i might do is i might go into my
camera
and to give it a little bit you know
when you're handheld you're not just up
and down side to side you're also moving
in and out a little bit so maybe i would
option click
and add my wiggle
expression and
maybe it's once
every second and it's
moving by 500 let's get into trial and
error here
might be two yeah that's too much
maybe 200.
that's pretty interesting
it's a nice imperfect camera move right
hand held or kind of shaky
but also smoothed out the same time so
pretty interesting stuff here
and then while we're doing this i want
to show you another little trick with
expressions because i know a few of you
have asked about expressions so i'm
going to hit return make a new line here
i'm going to add another expression here
called posterize
time posterize and then capital t
ime
parentheses and i'm going to enter a
value for like a frame rate so let's
just try 12. frame rate of 12
enter on my numeric keypad
and this is going to make it look a
little bit more jittery
which sometimes can have a pretty cool
effect
yeah i don't know maybe not for this one
so much maybe if i change this to 10
let's see what that is oh that's too
much yeah
i'll change it back to one and we'll
change the posterize time to let's say
18.
yeah that's pretty interesting
so just by
using everything we've learned so far
and applying that to a 3d camera we've
made our 3d camera that much more
interesting
in terms of its movement direction okay
so i want to show you one more thing
here which is going to make this
pretty cool
let's go ahead and
turn off this expression
let's reset this null let's make it 3d
again but let's reset it
and let's also
set that back to there okay so now we've
got our null our camera in our
layers of 3d here right
so in the previous week we talked about
animation composer we also talked a
little bit about it this week with the
anchor point but i want to jump back
into animation composer again and i want
to show you the power of anacommation
composer
based on what we've just
you know worked with so
you have to buy this pack 3d uh motion
presets
it does come with a few of them in the
free version but i went ahead and
purchased it a long time ago i've used
it extensively for some of my two and a
half d work in after effects but under
3d layer transformations here
we've got different ways to to move
things around
and
under position
i found this one kind of interesting
um there's one called overshoot you
could you can see it here
moves in overshoots slightly comes back
right and then there's one here it's a
little more extreme and here's one
that's kind of in the middle so maybe
we'll do this one in the middle here
and
maybe we'll make it come from the bottom
okay so right now you're just seeing it
move up on the y axis there's no z
movement but let me show you the power
of this with the 3d camera so what we'll
do is we'll select our null our camera
is parented to our null like it was
we'll select our null
we'll select the bottom 3d layer
transformation and we'll hit apply
and then we're going to go back to our
timeline here we're going to
set the end of our timeline to 312.
ish and
[Music]
we can already see if i preview this
what's going on
all right it's already kind of
interesting to see when it comes in you
can see that bounce you can see the the
two and a half d the layers moving a
little bit separately there
so
what
happens here is if i go up here to my
controls
you can see that there's the x is at
zero
the y is at 900 and the z is at 0. so if
i change this to let's say negative
2 000 so now it's way back in z space
mess with the y i'm going to take it up
so it's off camera
i'm also going to extend this
slightly
and look how much more interesting that
motion is
so all of a sudden our 3d camera just
got way more interesting
uh with its movement right if we were
moving into like some type of graphic or
something like that you can see the
possibilities here so
say i thought this was cool but it's not
quite it's not there for me so well i
didn't talk about this before but how
would you remove this well it's real
simple
you could just go in here and you say
i want to remove
the preset and boom it's gone
it doesn't do anything anymore okay
let me show you another one here let's
see
here's another good one
well let's go back to that one let's
just do the
the first overshoot and let's do it from
the top
this is a little less
of an overshoot a little more subtle
which i tend to lean towards the more
subtle effects and i'm pretty sure a lot
of motion gra you know graphic artists
that
something you know more subtle is better
it doesn't have to be when we're doing
like an overshoot effect it doesn't have
to be some extreme overshoot where it
flies in and bounces way back and flies
you know about you know
subtle
always works the more subtle something
is the less that the person's eye like
notices that as an overshoot the better
that you've done your job
okay so let's see how this one looks
so maybe on this one maybe we uh maybe
we make the camera start in tight
and then shoot back so we could do
something like so
yeah that's pretty cool
just a little bit here
yeah i like that
we could also uh if we decided we love
this move but we do want more overshoot
instead of one bounce maybe we want
three
just type in the three there and boom we
have a ton of overshoot now
very elastic
like here's five
tons overshoot but i mean you get the
idea very uh kind of cartoony here which
could work for a lot of different
applications
so
that's what i want to show you there's
also you know more transitions in here
like rotation
you could um you know easily rotate
around an anchor point like we actually
let me show you that really quick
let's go back into this let's delete
this let's remove this preset
let's
let's do something a little bit
different here
let's go ahead and make a new
composition
and we'll call this box
and right here we're going to do
a new
cinema 4d file
let's call this box two
save that
we're going to click right here to make
a cube
there's our cube and
you've seen that we've been working with
null objects but let's do this a little
differently let's add a null inside of
cinema 4d and how do we do that we just
go up here to create
object null right it's right there in
the center of our
scene
i'm going to add a tag to this null so
that after effects will read this null
if it doesn't have a tag it can't read
it real simple null
tag
cinema 4d tags
external compositing what does that mean
you don't have to do anything here
external compositing just means that any
external compositing application like
after effects will see this null object
if i tell it to it'll see this object
and it'll read this object okay
so i'm going to go back to file
save
back in after effects
and when you watch the form list and you
understand kind of how this works how
after effects sees this cinema 4d file
in here and what we're looking at so
that shouldn't be this shouldn't be
totally new to you at this point if it
is go back and watch form
so under renderer we're going to change
it from software to standard
there it is
here's the difference in this lesson i
am going to extract
the cinema 4d scene data okay when i
click this it's going to extract from
whatever this whatever layer is
highlighted here it's going to pull out
any data right the data that we have is
we have a camera which we can't see here
but there's a default camera inside of
cinema 4d
there's also a null object and for after
effects to read it has to have this tag
under cinema 4d tags external
compositing which we added that
jump back into after effects
let's go ahead and click extract
and there you go there's our null object
and there's our camera
last thing we need to do
is we need to tell this cinema 4d file
to reference this camera because like
right now if i go in and i move this
camera
you can see the null object moving there
right it's moving around but the box the
cube is not moving because it doesn't
know to reference the after effects
camera
all you have to do is select the cinema
4d file
we're going to go back and we're going
to change it
to the comp camera
right so the comp camera had a different
setting in terms of focal length which
is why the scene jumped back
super simple just to get back into that
you know similar distance we were at by
just hitting c on the keyboard going
through my camera tools here
and zooming in
all right so there we are pretty much
back to where we were
now
i want to show you this trick based on
how we had the flat layer before
in this file
i'm sorry if i'm jumping around here i
just have a lot to show you guys
remember when we rotate it around this
layer with the null object the camera
was parented to the null object we
rotate it around we're going to do that
here but with the cinema 4d file in
after effects
so we're going to parent this camera to
this null
and to this null we're going to apply
animation composer
so let's just find something
ease rotate around the anchor point
maybe let's do another uh uh
maybe let's do another overshoot
again
yeah that one's kind of cool
and we'll do it from
oh we'll do this one from the left okay
so null object selected
and go from the left we're gonna hit
apply
and you can see now our camera is flying
around
the cube from a center point
it takes a little bit longer to render
this preview
there we go
and it's super quick it's rotating
around very quickly
as you slow that down just slightly
and let's actually
turn the number of balances down to 2
and the angle down to like maybe
negative 60.
i'm going to go ahead and go to half res
here
so you can see this
quicker two bounces
and done
so again you can see the power in this
with using animation composer a null
object and a camera we have a ton of
control over how things move in the
directions inside of after effects with
our motion graphics and in this case a
full 3d layer or in the previous case
a
two and a half d layer so that wraps up
our lesson on movement and direction in
this two-part series
lots of basic building blocks here
in these lessons and you might have
started watching like these first couple
lessons saying oh this is really basic
material i already know all the stuff
but as we build and build and build
things get more and more complicated
and you can see the power of of
utilizing these different building
blocks on top of one another to build
more complex movement and direction
inside of motion graphics so that's what
i've got for you today i hope you guys
enjoyed this leave a comment let me know
what you thought and i'll talk to you
guys real soon see ya bye